more than 40 million male chickens are
gassed or drowned every year in Germany
because male birds don't lay eggs on
Thursday a court will decide if that
practice can't continue animal rights
campaigners have complained about the
killing of the chicks for years they
promote dual purpose chickens animals
that are suitable for laying eggs as
well as for fattening but fattening male
chicks takes longer and is more
expensive consumers will have to fork
out around 25 euros for a bird from a
dual-purpose barn in the past and may
all check like this one wouldn't have
been long for the world that perhaps a
mecha hatchery they were always killed
immediately after hatching Christine
Hetson occur didn't want to take part in
their killing anymore so he switched to
another breed both the female and male
chicks survive the Bavarian poultry farm
is an exception to the rule when it
comes to raising chickens most
industrial poultry farms are not fans of
the so-called dual purpose chicken I
don't have to guess my male chicks
because we sell both sexes the breed we
use is they blur their heavy white
chickens and because this is a
dual-purpose breed the females are
raised until they're sold for egg
production and the male chicks are
fattened and sent to slaughter master
chick culling is a common practice on
large poultry farms in Germany millions
of chicks are gassed because they don't
produce enough meat though not all of
the dead birds simply go to waste some
of them are fed to zoo animals
poultry industry representatives fear
that many hatcheries in Germany will be
out of business if chip culling is
banned Louis me it is yes finalizing new
we raised 32 million hens every year and
for that we need hatching eggs or there
be gaps in supplies foreign directories
or German ones that move abroad would
then supply us from Poland or Holland in
future animal welfare would suffer
anyway because the regulations don't
apply there the poultry industry wants
modern technology to determine the sex
of eggs to stop male chicks being born
scientists in Leipzig and Dresden are
working on a method using infrared light
and blood cell analysis but the method
still has to prove itself in large-scale
industrial application and the German
Animal Welfare Association is not 100%
satisfied with gender determination in
eggs
it might help stop chick culling but
really we have a broken system the
specialized breeds are over bred and the
animals suffer
we need more dual purpose chickens that
are suitable for both meat and eggs
poultry breeder christiane Hetson akka
is making a good living from his dual
purpose chickens
he sells four hundred thousand young
hens and fattened roosters every year
the chickens are particularly popular
with gourmet restaurants